Oh
everyone yeah thanks for being here on a
Sunday afternoon second last session of
the day
yeah today I'm going to tell you about
my journey over the last 18 months in my
my most recent job where we have
deployed a new big python powered
product in a big Hornet organization
with a really good team
it's a bit of a cautionary tale so in
the spirit of publishing negative
results I'm going to go through the kind
of mistakes that we made along the way
I've not spoken about it before so
hopefully it's going to be a bit of a
therapy session for me to get all of the
year all the demons out it's going to be
quite similar to some other talks that
being that I've gone on in the past just
quite a lot of people would take some of
the subjects but I'm going to kind of
hopefully put a bit of a different
perspective on it so as an overview of
what I'm going to talk about I thought
I'd do it as an air phase I because
trendy new technologies I'll do a quick
intro on me and the team I try not to
spend too long on that even though I'm
very narcissistic I'm going to then go
through the product that we built at the
BBC which is a mobile app and the
technology choices we made I'm going to
hopefully go into a bit of a bit of
detail about those technologies because
this is unlike this as a kind of a
novice session and it would be good to
warn people on on their kind of pitfalls
of some of that as we go and then yeah
just as a last caveat this is a year run
from when we started this project so
perhaps some of the messages and some of
my criticisms and some of my praises
might be out of date yeah that's good so
this is me kind of I haven't really been
able to choose a profession over the
last 10 years or so so I've done a few
different things most of it in software
the most fit in research so I started
off after my electronic engineering
degree doing a PhD in trains where I did
a lot of stuff to do with a Semantic Web
so this isn't the first presentation
I've given on like what technologies not
to use
I then started with BBC research and
development a few years ago and had the
luxury of working on quite a few really
fun projects I did some software-defined
radio stuff in Python new radio which is
really cool
some audio thumbnailing stuff in Python
and then some kind of web prototyping
stuff in node.js and that kind of thing
nowadays I'm a data engineer by my name
whether I'm kind of doing half software
engineering half data engineering or
quite a new team so I don't know who was
here in 2018 this time a year ago my
colleague Theo did a presentation on the
Semantic Web and how it is going to be
amazing and how we were gonna use it not
gone quite to plan but that's the same
thing that I'm in I think we have about
30 people overall in the team now we're
a centralized machine learning team in
the BBC there's a lot of other teams
doing data science of various types but
we're a kind of a central kind of hub of
supposed expertise
there's about 12 devs / scientists on
the team and we work together and we're
supported by a really good product team
we mostly do recommendations and we work
together so we don't have the data
scientists throw work over the fence to
the engineers for production ization we
try to pair on everything and try to and
come up with products that got a kind of
sustainable in short this is what data
does we take BBC content BBC has a huge
amount of content some main business I
metadata about the content which we're
also fortunately really good at we've
got all of our metadata about the TV
programs radio programs and the website
all in one place so that we can get to
it it's not particularly rich but it's
all right an audience data so we we
track what signed-in users have watched
and listened to and we allow them to
explicitly personalise some bits of the
website so we take all that stuff and we
use that to provide recommendations of
content for for them so a year ago the
team we just formed and we were a kind
of a technology team looking for a
problem
so I said we were a machine-learning
team we didn't actually get employed to
solve any specific problem we thought
we'd find it as we go and the first
thing we did was what every trendy new
team doesn't build a mobile app so the
BBC has a bit of a problem that our when
you ask people to describe the BBC in
terms of a person most people say like
55 year-old man radio for not much for
the young people at all so we thought
that by trying to create a and
experience to deliver short form content
in a more of a discoverable way a bit
like I mean attend if this resembles any
other app to youth yeah then maybe we
could entice them in and and and serve
those audiences a bit more effectively
so we bought a mobile app we employed an
app team and we had no idea really what
we were doing besides recommendations
this is where the problem started so
about well 18 months ago we were talking
about this app we had the beginnings of
a team to build the front end of the app
thankfully we didn't do that and there
were all these phrases being bandied
about so we'll have other customers we
need to build a platform we need to make
everything reusable because this isn't
going to be the only product we build
we're a new team we've got buy-in from
all the management so we can try a load
of new technology we don't really know
what the requirements are yet but we can
just build flexibly never do that so our
response to all this was just to go dive
into all of the new things that were
being talked about we were quite into
exploring Google Google cloud platform
most of the BBC is on AWS so we thought
I would do something different we use
Google and they recommended a whole host
of solutions as well now these are all
really good really good things but if
you're a small team you probably don't
want to buy into all of them at once the
next bit of the presentation is going to
be a little bit towards the kind of
software engineering deployment Leaside
but I try and bring it back to data and
science as we go on
so I'm now going to talk through the
specific technology choices that we made
what kind of worked and what didn't work
a lot of it didn't work
first thing microservices who's built
stuff with micro services cool and
there's a lot of skepticism now it's
good and micro services are meant to be
is meant to be a way of designing
software that so that you can break
everything down into the smallest
possible components deploy them
independently and then you can scale
each bit of the software so that you can
get the most out of your computer
infrastructure that's really great if
you're building a kind of a platform
that's serving millions of users we
didn't have any users and we decided to
build something I think I think I
counted 17 boxes on this diagram now
that's fine
but I think we probably could have done
it with three we had a kind of a
recommendations component in the middle
in green a data ingest component which
is the purple bit at the bottom which is
grabbing all of the new stuff that the
content creators are making and then a
client API to talk to react up in orange
but you know we chose this it didn't go
too badly but the problem is when you
have 17 different components any of the
practical things that you do so
deployment CI code quality onboarding
it's all multiplied 17 times you can't
just do something with one repository as
an alternative to that if I were
starting again now I probably just tried
to bring on a single VM or using
something like Heroku where you can just
push your code to get and see it working
immediately and then as we scaled out we
could have been refactored and tried
something different it's good to throw
code away just as some proof this is our
team not the whole BBC this is our team
which has 24 members 80 repositories in
it at the moment it gets to be a bit of
a headache next technology when you've
got 17 components you really need a
really trendy way of interfacing between
them so if you were going to build two
services connected by a network
what technology would you use to
communicate between them anyone yeah
okay rest and then he said gr PC this is
G our PC it's a way of doing remote
procedure calls over a network there
Google of developed over the last couple
of years it's kind of really cool
because it's meant to be really quick it
allows you to write Python code and
interface with your other applications
as if they're libraries and it uses cool
technology binary over HTTP to use meant
to be really really good and it
generates skeleton code for you this is
this is Python 3 code with yeah methods
for camel case and all sorts and we
can't change that so yeah really good in
practice sorry really good in theory but
in practice there's no tooling there's
there's basically one command-line
utility tool GRP curl which you have to
compile from source nobody in the team
knew it and all of the problems were
really hard to debug
so yeah it's got these these theoretical
advantages you can do really nice API
changes because then you can design API
has to be backward compatible but in
reality until you are scale just use
just use REST API or even don't bother
with the restful stuff anything over
HTTP is fine just as an addendum as well
the G RPC is meant to be meant to be
fast the Python implementation is about
1/10 as fast as to go implementation so
you're really not getting in very much
so verdict the price paid by the team's
way too high just use proven technology
ok so we're going a bit higher level now
when you work at a big company like
Google Airbnb Netflix they tend to have
ways of developing in the cloud for very
good reason they have their established
ways in-house everything's a bit
different at the BBC we're not quite at
that scale but we have a really good
team in
that helps us with our cloud
infrastructure a few years ago they gave
a talk AWS reinvent about the the new
framework think that they were going to
get the whole of the BBC to use to
deploy software to the cloud
it's called cosmos and it's actually
really good so as long as you can get
your Python code or your your JavaScript
code or anything you're writing into a
CentOS rpm package so into a Linux
installable thing you can use this
system and get stuff deployed with auto
scalars on Amazon with all the security
you need no problem at all so you get
for free monitoring access control
security reproducibility if I want to
limit my web app just to BBC developers
I can just say dependency developer sets
BBC and that will put a reverse proxy in
front of everything which will only
allow people with BBC client
certificates in so why would we leave
this behind well because we're a new
team we're trying yourself so this is
the the front lawyer you can't really
see that can even this is a front page
of the Google cloud platform sales pitch
and that's what we decided to go with so
everything at the BBC is on Amazon we
don't want to be too locked into one
cloud writer so we even got someone up
high saying oh yeah you should try GCP
let's try and do something in another
cloud and we were really excited because
there's all this new stuff there's a
load of really cool machine learning
tooling there's a load of kind of
pre-rolled API you can use and there's
always other stuff that we never touch
but we kind of forgot about all the
stuff that the team in in the central
BBC had built for us on Amazon so we had
to just completely start again so all of
the access control even even monitoring
we just had to start again
so when you start using Google clouds
what's the natural thing to do you don't
just use VMs you don't just build stuff
in the same way that you have had you
use docker in Cuba Nettie's now I
actually really like docker I've been
using it for prototyping things for ages
and I think unless there's any security
professionals in the room I think most
people kind of find it quite quite good
the security implications are a little
bit weird and so that's why we're not
using in the rest of the BBC yet but in
general docker allows you to take your
application install it as if it's on a
fresh computer and then package that up
into a container that container will run
identically in any environment as long
as you've got the the Linux hypervisor
and so you've got this this this kind of
self-contained artifact that you can
just treat as a thing and version
kubernetes is really cool as well I
really really like it having used it for
a year it's a container Orchestrator so
rather than in something like Amazon Web
Services or wherever you would declare
your infrastructure as code you declare
your auto-scaling
and bring up on Amazon autoscaler you
declare your load-balancing in your
security policies you can do that all as
declarative manifests in the system
called kubernetes install kubernetes on
all of your servers and then that piece
of software will work out where to run
all of your applications and where to
redirect all of your traffic so it's
really cool but really complicated what
helps a little bit was that we use
Google's managed version of kubernetes
which I highly recommend if you are
going to go for something as complicated
as this then don't roll it yourself use
some cloud providers version and just as
a little illustration at the bottom
because it like this slide was a bit
boring if you've got a few different
applications which are these different
different shapes different colored
shapes kubernetes will just make sure
that you're making the best use out of
all of the capacity that you're paying
for
so finally in terms of the technology
from the deployment side that I'm going
to talk about I think what's that three
or four brand new things I've already
introduced in a team of what was then
about eight people we needed a
continuous delivery solution because
when you're building software you want
to iterate you want to fail fast you
want to do all these great things and in
order to do that you can't just use your
standard out of the box being around for
ages continuous delivery system the BBC
has a customized version of Jenkins that
you can deploy in about half an hour now
we wanted to use something that you
could do Bluegreen deployments you could
do multivariate testing out of the box
and it's got a shiny new user interface
so we chose a piece of software called
spinnaker which is a kind of a multi
cloud multi target continuous delivery
system again like most of these
technologies have mentioned spinnaker is
really cool so you can describe your
infrastructure you can put it in there
you can tell it how you wanted to deploy
things you can build pipelines so that
if you're deploying a new algorithm or a
new piece of software a new version can
go through a series of steps you can do
manual intervention and then eventually
promote it to production the problem is
this gets installed well there's no
managed service for this its ups running
it on our kubernetes cluster which we've
only just learned how to use and it
installs about 40 different components
so we had more downtime and more
incidents as a result of this piece of
software than we did any of the bugs
that we'd written in our Python code
just a disclaimer I think since we got
rid of this last year it's come on quite
away and a lot of the bugs and a lot of
the misconceptions that we have have
disappeared and the documentation got a
lot better so if you're in the market
for a complicated continuous delivery
system this is probably the thing to go
for not for us so eventually we ripped
it out and we replaced it with a git
repo with all of our codes just in there
as yeah more files
and a hook into the Google cloud so if
we want to deploy a new piece of
software now we build the docker image
push it up to taka manually and then
change your manifest on github press go
do a code review and it goes into stage
and then we've wrote into prod that
seems like a bit of a clunky process
because when I'm editing the image
manually I could get it wrong but we've
had no problems with this in the last
six months and we had so many problems
to the previous approach so go as simple
as possible and you'll be you'll be
grand just to illustrate that look at
how many slack emojis we got once we
once we deleted spinnaker I don't even
know what some of them are so all of it
happened over about the first eight
months of 2018 we were building this
product on these new technologies we
were learning new things which is refund
but it took ages and then the kind of
the last four months as we were
releasing this product for the public
it's now available on all your favorite
app stores by the way we decided to
scale it in a little bit and we learned
some lessons so our pace dropped
significantly in the first part of 2018
from what we'd expected we ended up with
quite low confidence in the code that we
were building and quite because we
didn't have a really easy way of testing
things locally microservices didn't have
the right boundaries so changing things
was a bit risky the 50% data scientists
in our team ended up working on
infrastructure because there was so much
of a burden on infrastructure so the
data science we were doing moved slowly
as well and bugs compounded I say team
arrived dropped we were lovely people so
we were carried on enjoying working one
last thing
by this point we still didn't have a
ninja spy plane and we thought you know
what let's get rid of the microservices
let's just build something that works we
spent about three weeks building a
single Python package that listened for
events coming in from
I'm metadata provider that it all
synchronously so this took about three
seconds per request and then dumped
everything into elastic search elastic
search by the way that's a database that
everybody uses it's got high Google
ability so we had no problems with that
whatsoever yeah so really in elegant
solution slowing inefficient the data
that can ends up in a sixer CH isn't
even particularly consistent and it
doesn't handle errors very well but it's
good enough if this does glitch out in
any way it will send a 4x s response
back to the Amazon simple notification
service and it will try again later
nowadays we are thinking of swapping it
out but for 12 months that's worked
perfectly another good thing jupiter hub
this is the one piece of new technology
that we've used that has really really
helped us I said that data science is
moving slowly since installing this our
data scientists have been able to work a
lot more effectively you probably most
of you know what Jupiter hub is already
but effectively it's a software as a
service that you can install yourself or
pay for a hosted solution that allows
your developers or data scientists to
have an IDE or a dupe to notebook
running in the cloud on some compute
resources that get provisioned for that
user so if I want to go and do some
really gnarly deep learning problem I
can go and go onto our Jupiter hub URL I
can say I want a really big computer
press go and it will spin me up an
interface where all of this code runs in
that really big computer Google have
just launched or relaunched their
gpnotebook offering on the cloud so we
might look back at that bird at the time
launching our own version writing the
install scripts and knowing exactly what
was going on was much more valuable than
going to somebody else who was doing a
cloud offering and not having an idea
what was installed other good ideas
elasticsearch managed logging so Google
provides a logging solution which
most people haven't used before that
using that over rolling our own saved us
a lot of time managed machine learning
model training Google ml engine which is
now called something like Google AI hub
train allows you to write a Python
package that solves some problem send a
command line command to the API upload
the Python code into the cloud run it
and it gets you back results so that
means that you can do your data science
without having to worry about
infrastructure at all that's the trendy
technology that's actually good and then
this is a bit of a painful one but for
now we're committing to using tensorflow
for as many of our recommendation engine
machine learning tasks as possible not
because it's necessarily the
best-in-class framework but because the
Googler state that we're in is so
optimized for solving tensorflow
problems lessons learnt this idea of
known unknowns versus unknown unknowns
when you choose these new technologies
it's very easy to think that they're the
best thing ever that you don't know what
you don't know when you form a new team
I think this probably goes for any size
of company you really need to be careful
with decision-making because we're all
lovely people in days love we initially
didn't really raise any objections to
any suggestions so someone would say oh
there's this new cool thing we could use
that to do this and everything okay yeah
that's a great idea let's try it
it's not the way you should do things
and the other thing especially in the
BBC it's easier to over engineer a
solution than it is to navigate
organizational politics so it's often
easier to just get your head down and
code stuff than it is suggesting that we
do some user research to start with on
that topic so this is a graph showing
the dunning-kruger effect from Wikipedia
this is the idea that as your expertise
on a subject goes up your confidence
drops so before you started or when
you've just got into it when you've just
gone to see a talk at PI data about some
technology you think it's great and you
do the tutorial and everything's cool
and you adopt it but as you learn more
and you find the glitches and you find
the places where it doesn't work and
your um your your confidence in it and
it drops this happened with basically
all of our technologies some of them
were coming out the other end some of
them we abandoned why do individuals
fall for this well there's this kind of
selection bias of people only talk at
meetups and conferences and only publish
blog articles on their successes you
don't really see people publishing their
failures particularly so when you see
this trendy new package you're only
hearing from the people who it worked
for and then maybe this effect of CV
driven development where I can now put
kubernetes on my CV I can now put
spinnaker on my CV and all of this stuff
Dan McKinley did a very similar talk on
this subject a few years ago but with
more of an emphasis on the kind of long
term intern ability of code and he said
the grim paradox of this law of software
is that you should probably be using the
tool that you hate the most you hate it
because you know the most about it so
yeah just go back to that Postgres
database oh yeah the other thing people
always say oh yeah but it's different
here we're solving a new problem
probably not true so I thought I'd try
and analyze why or from a really
informal AV why this was really a
problem and I realized that early on we
had so many stages for going from
developing an algorithm or developing a
feature in a piece of software through
to deploying it to a point where the
audience can see it though there was
only one member of the team that had
expertise in each stage so if you go
from left to right first of all you have
to start at a local dev developer
environment that was that's so that you
can try your software locally and make
sure it interacts with the other
services properly that's really
complicated so we need a help from one
of the developers you then write your
feature you then have to change
something about the G RPC interface
that's not straightforward either
because there's no documentation so you
have to ask somebody else
this goes on if you assume that it
probably takes about half a day to get
someone to come and help you that means
that you spent two and a half days
without thinking about the actual
writing of the feature just waiting for
other people to help and if you compare
that to the same thing running on the
kind of established BBC infrastructure
the only thing you have to do is as a
new starter at the BBC learn how like
Cosmo system works that'll probably take
a couple of weeks but then you can do
everything yourself yeah if you have a
monolithic gap or if you have just a few
components rather than lots of
components then you don't need to be
spinning up new infrastructure every
time you make a change don't look at the
next bit too closely but I did try to
model and what the cost of adopting
these new technologies was so that's a
bit blurry isn't it I try and explain it
done McKinley in his used boring
technology talk defined risk as total
maintenance cost of a technology minus
the total benefit I've kind of modified
that a little bit and I've introduced
this idea of kind of a pace cost or a
cost of developers in in the short term
so risk is
kind of inverse maturity plus inverse
support so an immature technology that
has very little documentation of support
get high risk and then you subtract the
familiar the familiarity or the
expertise and the team that to get your
kind of paste cost you can then combine
that with the the total cost that Dan
McKinley described by yeah effectively
adding the maintenance cost that you've
already estimated with the cut that with
the paste cost and to try out this is
not perfect by any means and any staff
physicians are welcome to come and help
me out afterwards you can start to get
numbers which you should definitely rely
on for the different technologies so
spinnaker adopting that cost me one
point for adopting airflow cost me not
point five adopting Postgres because we
all know it and we want to understand it
cost me well not nothing but close to
nothing so really briefly our next
challenge we've basically got the same
thing now that we had last January we're
embarking on a new problem and we wanted
to pick the right technologies and the
right approaches to solve it we're now
working on proper recommendation systems
that with that we're giving to other
clients within the BBC that we don't
have to worry about running ourselves so
the emphasis from the engineering point
of view is to try and allow the data
scientists to do their work reproducibly
and quickly so they're not leaving their
laptop one overnight training model we
want continuous integration because we
want to be able to continue working and
and we want reproducible data so the
knee-jerk reaction is to go to all of
the trendy technologies that we've been
hearing about I'm really sad that I
missed the the talk on production I use
machine learning yesterday and I have to
look it up on YouTube later but I'm sure
there's some far more sensible
suggestions
and I don't know what half of these
really do and I certainly don't know
where the downfalls and things are I've
already started to identify what they
don't do which is good but we're not
going to do that this time so run my
little algorithm comes up with different
costs for some of these things you know
it's at Jenkins at the bottom just using
an existing CI system for your machine
learning stuff and having to do a load
of the stuff manually and not having
highly efficient training might be the
best approach so at the moment we are
gonna try and solve our problems with
virtual machines with Jenkins and then
as we go on
do a few spikes which will guard really
closely some of these new technologies
and then think really hard about
adopting them so final thoughts this is
probably like being a broken record by
now fit your problem to your existing
technology it's kind of easier to kind
of fudge a solution based on something
you've already got running in your
organization than it is to run a new
thing shiny new shiny new technologies
are always alluring a lot of the open
source projects from the big tech
companies have got marketing teams and
and and branding people and they look
really awesome and there's no shortcut
for genuine expertise so it's really
easy to think oh yeah I'll become an
expert in that in the next six months or
so but really like it you know an expert
is five years or more so don't adopt
something unless you're willing to
commit yeah so that's it thanks very
much
I get that your recommendation is don't
pick new technology if you can avoid to
but occasionally you do need to because
you're working in their language that
your gazillion support what have you
learned about how you evaluate new
things that you look at in order to
accept to reject them as quickly as
possible
I think the trickiest thing at the
moment particularly where we're trying
to continue delivering things as
products is guarding the time that it
takes to properly explore and Spike out
a new technology so you can't just spend
two days on something and then build a
prototype because by the time you built
the prototype the product team don't
necessarily want you to rewrite
different scratch so really spend that
initial time investigating things
properly and try and hear from people
that have actually battled tested it I
guess yeah I think probably got a lot
more thoughts than that but thank you
very much for the talk very important
topic I wanted to ask like in bigger
organizations from my experience sort of
threes a lot of legacy especially for
the data and there is a lot of like
blockers just to get the data into a new
fancy system whereas in your case it
seems not a problem at all so can you
please cover that one yes I guess as
being part of this new team we were kind
of told to act like a start-up which is
sometimes really good advice and
sometimes not so good advice we're
really fortunate that the gatekeepers of
the content data and the audience data
that I mentioned in the previous slide
real pros and they they don't do this
just adopt whatever technology is
coolest they've got really solid
products and as long as we can have a
secure environment that we've worked on
and they can help us to get the data
once so I guess basically we just really
good at cooperating and at least at that
level
I think I really enjoyed that I wanted
to ask now based on your experience and
how you guys went about it how would you
prioritize which tools to decide on
first and then how would you split the
tasks because this one tool per person
didn't seem to work very well yeah so
two things and the first one is also
answers Max's question from earlier a
little bit thought work so thought works
published this thing called the tech
radar which if you haven't seen it is
worth checking out it's a big map and it
shows a lot of the new and up-and-coming
technologies and which ones they've
already evaluated and which ones they
think are good and a bad so resources
like that that are kind of quite
thorough endorsements of what might be
good and what might not in general are a
really good start I forgotten the other
thing that I was gonna say but I mean
yeah just kind of not well I I remember
right the other talk that I referenced
Dan McKinley's used boring technology
talk he gives the concept of like you
have three innovation tokens when you
start a project you can spend them
however you like but you only have three
of them so if you want to try this new
database that you think will solve your
problem and that uses up one of your
innovation tokens and so maybe that kind
of approach for a smaller team will work
quite well because you then kind of
rationalize everyone's enthusiasm for
new things but it's really tricky right
it's just and there's probably no
substitute for experience as well
John
[Applause]